this video is brought to you by Wix my
choice for building legal eagles website
I'm not a bad guy I know that and
there's emotional testimony I assume 85%
of it is exaggeration and the other 15
perjury accurate hey legal eagles it's
time to think like a lawyer today we are
covering the social network which is a
movie that I'm told is incredibly
realistic in fact I'm told that some of
the dialogue in this movie comes
directly out of the deposition testimony
that was taken in the various lawsuits
that were filed against Facebook founder
Mark Zuckerberg so this will be really
interesting from my perspective because
I've taken a lot of depositions and they
have a kind of sound to them so it'll be
interesting to see if this movie gets it
right as always be sure to comment in
the form of an objection which all
either sustain or overrule and stick
around until the end of the video where
i give the social network a grade for
legal realism so without further ado
let's dig in to the social network so
your calls in front of the ad board
that's not what happened all right so as
expected this movie deals a lot with
depositions what is a deposition a
deposition is an out-of-court
cross-examination essentially often
people think about the only time you're
under oath as being on the witness stand
in trial that's actually not true
most of the testimony that takes place
under oath takes place in a deposition
as you can see in this particular scene
there is a conference room which is
where most depositions take place and on
one side of the conference room table
you have the plaintiff in all of his
attorneys in a major case you're likely
to get two three four sometimes five
attorneys for each side it's not
uncommon to have the entire conference
room packed with attorneys if the stakes
are high enough and on the other side of
the table
you also have Mark Zuckerberg in this
case the defendant with his attorneys
separating the two sides is the court
reporter you can see her in the middle
here she has her laptop open but she is
typing into a stenographers keyboard
which is a phonetic keyboard that allows
her to type very very fast what would
have happened before the scene is the
sonographer would have asked Mark
Zuckerberg to raise
right hand and swear to tell the truth
and so essentially put him under oath so
that the testimony that he gives is
sworn testimony and if he lies under
oath and effectively he can be charged
with perjury a deposition is part of the
discovery process what you see on TV
with the trial is only the tip of the
iceberg
there are hundreds if not thousands of
hours that go into any particular trial
of discovery where you're trying to get
the facts to support your case so that
you're not blindsided at trial and a
deposition is one of the major tools
that you have in order to get the
testimony from the other side so you
know what they're going to say it is
possible for someone to change their
testimony at trial but if you do then
you can quote impeach them with the
testimony that they gave during their
deposition so what we're seeing here is
a spot-on representation of what a
deposition looks like in a multi-million
dollar case so so far so good this is
very accurate she said all that said
that stuff to her I was reading from the
transcript of her deposition why would
you even need to deposed her that's
really for us to decide I think if I
know she like a jerk I'll be more likely
to settle
yeah so it is proper to take someone
else's deposition testimony and ask
another witness what they think about it
this is not an impeachment she's not
contradicting Mark Zuckerburg
testimony here she is simply providing
the other testimony to get the witness's
reaction to it
when you see a cross-examination on TV
it's often very very heated but the
rules of a deposition are such that you
can basically ask whatever question you
want the only thing you're really not
allowed to ask in a deposition are
questions that are protected by
privilege but that doesn't seem to be
the case here why don't we stretch our
legs for a minute can we do that it's
been almost three hours and frankly you
did spend an awful lot of time
embarrassing mr. Zuckerberg with the
girls testimony from the bar I'm not
embarrassed she just made a lot of that
up she was under oath and I guess that
would be the first time somebody's lied
under oath so this may very well have
been taken right out of the deposition
transcript because it's often the case
where an attorney will ask to take a
break whether it's for lunch or whether
just to stretch your legs that is
exactly the kind of thing that a defense
lawyer a good one will do so that you
can have
time to break up the flow of the
questions for the plaintiff's attorney
and really just to take a break because
it's very very mentally taxing to be on
the other end of a deposition and the
reason I say this might be taken right
out of the deposition transcript is at
no time did any of the lawyers say ok
we're gonna go off the record which is a
signal to the stenographer to stop
taking down everything and unless you
tell the stenographer to stop typing she
will continue to take down everything
that you say
including this sort of mundane colloquy
between the defense attorney and the
plaintiff's attorney over whether
they're gonna take a break or not and
then Mark Zuckerburg alleged kind of
snippy dialogue where he's talking back
to the plaintiff's attorney all of that
could very well be on the record because
no one's said to go off of the record
which is what you would normally say so
I think this is this could be very real
testimony here Cameron Winklevoss WI &
que le vos cameras about to shoot tyler
winklevoss tyler spelled the usual way
and my last name is the same as my
brother's okay here we have another
deposition this time by the Winklevoss
twins it would be very very unusual to
have a deposition where you've
questioned two people at once that's
probably more for dramatic effect I
doubt that they took both of their
depositions simultaneously but if you go
back to the beginning of that scene you
get a really good view of what the
stenographer is doing she has a special
keyboard is hooked up to a laptop and it
writes everything down in special
software if you are an attorney you can
actually get a live readout of what's
going on and often that becomes very
very important to make sure that the
exact words that you want especially
when you're dealing for the contract
case where the words matter but to make
sure that the exact words come out and
are actually in the official record
because if the stenographer didn't hear
it that really doesn't exist anymore so
the sonographer is very very important
in terms of a deposition and as you can
kind of see on the stenographers laptop
screen almost everything that you get
out of a deposition is written in the
font courier I have no idea why it's
kind of hard to read and it looks really
really archaic but like screenwriters
and screenplays almost everything you
get out of a deposition is in this
courier font who
you said it was three or four years ago
I don't know what I said when did you
come to Eduardo I don't understand that
question
you remember answering in the
affirmative the affirmative when did you
come to a guarna with the idea for
Facebook it was called the Facebook
thing this doesn't need to be that
difficult this is actually kind of a
clever thing that they're doing in this
movie they're using Mark Zuckerberg his
testimony in two different lawsuits two
depositions spaced probably months or
years apart and comparing his testimony
between the two and in fact in the later
deposition that takes place in the the
darker room what he's doing is he's
reading back Zuckerberg testimony from
the prior lawsuit often people's prior
testimony will hurt them in other
lawsuits because the testimony that they
gave is good for a particular lawsuit
but it might be bad for a different
lawsuit that hinges on other facts and
law what the shows is also a funny
phenomenon that happens often in
depositions where a witness has been
over coached where the witness has been
told you don't want to give in to
questions even if they're easy answers
and what Zuckerberg has done here is he
has refused to answer basically that he
answered yes to a prior question that
really isn't in dispute if you want to
see a great example of this check out a
video called what is a photo copier put
out by the New York Times which is a
dramatization of a deposition just like
this one where someone refuses to answer
the question of what is a copy machine
or what is a photo copier when you say
photocopying machine what do you mean
they were essentially coached to well
and they refused to answer even the most
simple mundane questions and the lawyer
just goes apoplectic Joe you have such a
machine yes sir what do you call that
machine sometimes it's really hard to
get even very simple answers from a
highly coached witness there was a big
project and he was going to have to
write tens of thousands of lines of code
so I wondered why he was coming to me
and not his roommates Dustin Moskovitz
and Chris Hughes they were programmers
this scene doesn't make a whole lot of
sense because this appears to be the
exact same scene of Zuckerberg
deposition the plaintiff's lawyer is
asking questions of sucker
but it doesn't make any sense for
Eduardo Saverin to be testifying at
exactly the same deposition as Mark
Zuckerberg what I think the filmmakers
have done here is combined two different
depositions they're combining the
deposition of Zuckerberg with the
deposition of Saverin into the same
thing but you only get so many hours to
depose the witness that you want to
depose so you would never take up that
time by interviewing another witness on
the same day at the same time if this
was a very crucial witness as the
deposition of Mark Zuckerberg would be
so I think they just combined the two
together and it would it's not realistic
that Saverin is testifying essentially
in the middle of Zuckerberg testimony
here this is the first time he mentioned
any problem yes it was you sent 36
emails to mr. Zuckerberg and received 16
emails in return and this was the first
time he indicated he was not happy
that's correct he had 42 days to study
your system and get out ahead do you see
any of your code on Facebook did I use
any of your code you stole our whole
idea so it's possible that Zuckerberg
may have interjected into this
deposition of this other gentleman here
it's really really bad practice because
you don't want your witness to chime in
on someone else's witness's testimony
here but it appears that the lawyers are
trying to get a handle on their two
prospective clients to try to prevent
some interactions so it's very possible
that this is taken from real deposition
where Zuckerberg just became angry at
what the deponent was saying and then
was forced to be quiet by his own lawyer
I should note that it is totally proper
for Zuckerberg to be present during the
deposition of these other people in fact
there's many reasons why you would want
to do that if Zuckerberg is the one who
has all the crucial information he may
need to provide that information to his
attorney to know what questions to ask
her to know where people are lying
because you often only get one shot at
these depositions and it can't wait for
the testimony to be given back to your
client to get comments back and then get
to ask questions later that's not really
how it works so it often makes sense for
the party to be there in person to give
you real-time No
and at least with the Federal Rules of
Civil Procedure a named party can
absolutely be present during the
testimony of another witness like this
during the time when you say you had
this idea did you know Tyler and Cameron
came from a family of means a family of
means did you know their father was
wealthy I'm not sure why you're asking
me that it's not important you'd be sure
why I'm asking it's not important to you
sorry yeah so this might be taken
directly out of deposition testimony
here the witness does not get to pick
and choose what questions he or she
answers and whether or not Zuckerberg
was aware of the wealth of the
Winklevoss twins might be relevant to a
further line of questioning so you don't
get to fight it just because you think
it's irrelevant you have to answer the
questions that are given to you I went
to my friend for the money because
that's why I wanted to be partners
eduarda was the president of the Harvard
investors association and he was also my
best friend so I should point out that
in this deposition it's very very common
in a multi-million dollar deposition to
have it being video recorded part of the
value of asking these questions that a
witness is likely to say are irrelevant
or just basically foundational is that
you want the witness on camera fighting
you tooth and nail because often in a
deposition the witnesses are not on
their best behavior because they don't
realize that their testimony might come
back to haunt them so often they're on
their best behavior in trial in front of
a jury and a judge
whereas in front of a camera they forget
it's there and they might be kind of
jerks to the other side and you might be
able to use that to destroy their
credibility later on especially whatever
someone refuses to answer a very simple
question like did you know someone came
from wealth in a situation like this
Gretchen they're best friends not
anymore we already went through this on
the nevermind mr. Saverin that's a
really funny interaction between the two
attorneys there's no rule that requires
one attorney to refer to a witness as a
specific thing or not but often you
might just interject that to break up
their flow and to fluster them a little
bit and get them speaking in your terms
so that the record reflects things the
way you want them reflected nineteen
Nobel laureates 15 poster prize winners
two future Olympians and a movie star
doesn't matter that does not sound like
deposition testimony that sounds like
something written by Aaron Sorkin you
don't want any lunch no you're welcome
to this is a really accurate scene so
far all the partners have gone to lunch
they're out of the office
leaving one junior associate to
basically play babysitter with the
client to make sure that they don't do
anything stupid this must be hard warden
I'm Marylin Delpy I introduced myself I
mean what do you do I'm a second-year
associate at the firm my boss wanted me
to sit in on the deposition pays very
accurate the way that junior associates
get experience is they get to sit in on
depositions like this so they can see
how it's done
so they can learn the tactics and if the
client can afford it it's a great way
for junior associates to gain experience
well as efo I had set up some meetings
with potential advertisers who paid for
the trims pay for the thousand-dollar
count myself a few months earlier at
this point your $1,000 was the only
money that had been put into the company
yes how did you feel the meetings went
it went terribly again this doesn't make
a lot of sense because Eduardo Saverin
lawyer is the one that's questioning
Eduardo Saverin usually that doesn't
happen there's not much to be gained for
creating testimony from your own client
the point of a deposition is to get
adverse testimony from your opponent so
the plaintiff's lawyer is going to
question Mark Zuckerberg and Mark
Zuckerberg attorney is going to quest
wardo Saverin it's very rare to get
deposition testimony out of your own
client because you never know what kind
of stupid things your client is going to
say when you're not the one controlling
that testimony instead what you would
want to do if you want to get testimony
out to support a motion like a summary
judgment motion is to file what's called
an affidavit which is a written
declaration of what your client swears
to you can attach exhibits to it you can
say whatever you want as long as it's
truthful and then the client has to sign
off on it so there's really no reason
why you want to get verbal testimony
from your own client when you can always
get written testimony later on going to
enter this into the record and
corporation papers for face book and LLC
registered in Florida why Florida my
family and ask the respondent to
stipulate that the Articles of
Incorporation estate the ownership as
follows sixty-five percent from Mark
Zuckerberg
30 percent for Eduardo Saverin and five
percent for Dustin Moskovitz yeah we
stipulate and that was April 13th 2004
you can market so this is really really
accurate when you're doing a deposition
you often deal with physical exhibits
all the time
emails articles of incorporation like
this any physical paperwork that needs
to be talked about first you have to
mark it as an exhibit to the deposition
you of course need to describe what
you're going to be talking about and
then put a number on it so that you can
always refer back to say exhibit 35 is
the Articles of Incorporation so the
dialogue is going on right here is a
hundred percent accurate
anytime you deal with a physical exhibit
in a deposition you've got a market you
got to add it to the record and then
it's not entered into evidence per se
it's just an exhibit to that deposition
and often you'll refer back to that in
other depositions or throughout that
particular deposition Eduardo can you
please repeat the question no it was now
rageous lee lived in question the first
time around and now you want us to hear
it twice would you read it back please
go ahead counsel and when you sign these
documents were you aware that you were
signing your own death certificate no
that's a great tactic so the sonographer
as I already talked about is constantly
taking down everything and often the
opposing attorney won't like the
question
that you are asking and one way to get
around that just as a rhetorical device
is to ask the stenographer to read back
the question that you asked and often as
what happens here the witness actually
just answers the question without you
having to re answer it and without the
other attorney objecting to it here you
could kind of hear that the opposing
attorney was objecting to the question
as misleading it's not usually a proper
objection the rules of evidence don't
really apply in the deposition you're
allowed to ask whatever questions you
want and often when I'm dealing with
obstreperous opposing counsel I'll do
the exact same thing I'll ignore the
opposing counsel and just simply ask the
court reporter to read back the question
that I originally asked and I will often
get an answer to my question I'm not a
bad guy I know that there's emotional
testimony I assume 85% of it is
exaggeration and the other 15 perjury
accurate what happens now
sigh and the others are having a steak
on University Avenue then I'll come back
up to the office and start working on a
settlement agreement to present to you
you're gonna settle oh yeah and you're
gonna have to pay a little extra why so
that these guys sign a nondisclosure
agreement
they say one unflattering word about you
in public you on their wife and kids I
invented Facebook yeah so there's some
truth to that I think that generally
what happens after a deposition is not
going straight to settlement really
what's gonna happen is a motion for
summary judgment which is basically like
a trial but on paper you take all of the
depositions you take all of the exhibits
you put them down on paper you make your
most convincing argument and you say
that even taking the evidence in the
light most favorable to the other party
that you're against it still supports
your side as a matter of law in the
grand scheme of things the $500,000 that
it takes to put together a summary
judgment motion is nothing compared to
the billions of dollars that are at
stake and potentially at stake in this
settlement agreement or the the lawsuit
in general so most likely the next step
would be summary judgment and only then
would you go after settlement and if
settlement failed then you would go
after trial that's why ninety-eight
percent of cases settle first
before going to trial because the stakes
are too high and you never know which
way a jury is going to go I have been
licensed to practice law for all of 20
months and I could get a jury to believe
that you planted the story about it
water on the chicken watch what else why
weren't you at Shawn's sorority party
that night you think I'm the one that
called the police doesn't matter I asked
a question now everybody's thinking
about it you've lost your jury in the
first 10 minutes some truth to that I
was angry and blogging and blogging
pay them and scheme of things it's a
speeding ticket yeah for better or worse
that's often true for a huge corporation
making these kind of settlements is an
easier thing to do than to roll the dice
and go to trial where you might lose
hundreds of millions or billions of
dollars all right that was the social
network now let's give it a grade for
legal realism
so much of this movie is told through
depositions and it appears that a lot of
the dialogue was taken directly out of
the deposition testimony you can tell
when there's back and forth between
these lawyers are they're asking for a
lunch break or they've been going for
too long that's exactly what a lawyer
would say and the dialogue is spot-on
right down to marking an exhibit to go
into the record I don't know that I've
ever seen a depiction of a deposition
more accurate than what we saw here on
the other hand I think that there is
some cinematic license taken where they
are conflating different depositions
together they're having the wrong
attorney ask the questions here the
witness at one point was turned
completely around and wasn't even
looking at the camera that would never
be allowed it's all for dramatic effect
but notwithstanding this was one of if
not the most accurate legal drama I have
ever seen in my entire life I think
largely because they used the deposition
testimony as the reference material for
the movie itself so with all of that
under consideration I'm giving the
social network in a - it's clear you did
well at Harvard it's a little-known fact
but the character in the movie Mark
Zuckerberg is actually based on a real
person who went on to create one of the
biggest websites in the world you might
even heard of it
the facebook.com now if you're going to
be an internet billionaire you first
need to start with a stellar website
when I needed a website for helping law
school students I chose Wix Wix helped
me create an e-commerce store in a law
school blog I've used them for years and
have paid for the websites with my own
money so I'm thrilled they're now a
sponsor I looked at other website
builders but they were too constricting
the templates were fine but I couldn't
change them how I wanted to Wix allowed
me to build an awesome professional
website that let me be as creative as I
wanted to be the click-and-drag
interface was incredibly easy to use and
let me build exactly the website I
wanted to help law students kick ass in
law school if you're looking to build
your own website you have to check out
Wix the first 100 legal eagles will get
10% off just click on the link below and
use the code legal eagle at checkout so
get out there and make the next Facebook
with Wix